>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Kurt Dewhurst: I'm Kurt Dewhurst.
I am the Chair of the
Board of the Trustees
of the American Folklife Center
here at the Library of Congress
and I really want to welcome you
to this really very special event,
something we've been looking forward
to for actually a number of years
as we started to think
about our 40th anniversary.
Today's roundtable
discussion is part
of the American Folklife Center's
active year-round commitment
to public programming, a commitment
that includes, as many of you know,
the Benjamin A. Botkin
lecture series,
the Homegrown concert series, in
symposia on a wide range of topics,
Open Mic interviews and
numerous other special events.
These public programs
form an important part
of the Center's acquisitions
activities.
Each event is videotaped
and becomes part
of the Library's permanent
collections.
In addition, the videos of these
events are posted to the Library
of Congress website where
they are available for viewing
for internet patrons
certainly throughout the world
and we've been finding more and
more that people are using these,
which is very gratifying for us.
As many of you know, this year,
because we are celebrating
our 40th anniversary
at the American Folklife Center,
we're doing a number
of special activities.
The Center was created in 1976
by the US Congress "to preserve
and present American folklife
through programs of research,
documentation, archival
presentation, reference service,
live performance, exhibitions,
publications, and training.
Designed by Congress as "a national
Center for folklife," it continues
to play an important role in
the documentation, research
and the Center continues to collect
and document living traditional
culture, while preserving
for the future its
unparalleled archival collections
in state-of-the-art, preservation
facilities of the Library
of Congress that continually are
upgraded and we're very grateful
for that opportunity to be able
to make these collection
so available now.
In addition to its active
public programming schedule,
the Center's archive houses the
largest ethnographic collection
in the world.
As of 2016, its holdings
include more than 5 million items
of ethnographic documentation
that record folklore
and traditional expressions
of the United States
and other nations throughout
the world.
The AFC archives includes
outstanding holdings
of sound recordings of more than
350,000 hours in diverse formats
and over 800,000 photographs,
field notes
and other manuscript
materials, videotapes
and other visual formats and,
of course, ephemera dating
from the late 19th century
through the present day,
but the archive's peerless
recordings didn't appear magically,
as you know.
Over the years, the Center's growth
and increasing prominence were
guided by the dedicated efforts
of its staff and heading that staff
are the Center's current director
and two former directors,
who are with us today.
And for this discussion, we'll
have a rich opportunity to be able
to hear directly from them and I
might say they haven't had a chance
to rehearse or prepare for how
this might go and I think they're
as anxious to hear from one another.
So, I want to ask you to join me
in welcoming Dr. Alan Jabbour,
who led the Center from its
beginning to-- from 1976 to 1999,
Dr. Peggy Bulger who headed
the Center from 1999 to 2012,
and the current AFC
Director Betsy Peterson,
who assumed this leadership
of the Center in 2012.
Now, before you-- we welcome them
officially, I'm going to turn
over the proceedings to my
colleague, Cliff Murphy,
who is the Director of
Folk and Traditional Arts
at the National Endowment for the
Arts and who has kindly agreed
to serve as moderator for
this roundtable discussion
of the Center's historical
initiatives and programs
as well as its future prospects.
But before I do, I want to
thank you again for coming today
and for your interest in
the unique cultural treasure
that really is a cultural
treasure of our nation,
the American Folklife Center.
Please join me in welcoming
our panel and our moderator.
[ Applause ]
>> Cliff Murphy: Hello everybody.
I'm Cliff Murphy and it's my
pleasure and honor to be up here
and to moderate, though, admittedly
I imagine that I have three--
the three tops here that once we
let them go, they're just going
to run their own course here, so I
have an easy job of steering, right?
And I may have to pat
you on the shoulder or--
>> Alan Jabbour: While
we're spinning.
>> Cliff Murphy: Yes, while
you're spinning just say, "Hey,
let's let Betsy speak,"
for instance.
[ Laughter ]
Betsy being the junior, yes?
So before we do that and, you know,
I am sitting thinking this is a
really remarkable moment for all
of us and for our discipline.
I think that in the time Alan
that you first took the helm
of the Center, we've had--
over that time, we've had,
I think seven sitting
presidents, right,
and yet we have three
directors of the Center.
And I'm not even trying to be funny.
I think that--
>> Alan Jabbour: Wow,
I never counted that.
That's amazing.
>> Cliff Murphy: Yeah.
And I think here in the audience,
I see Barry Bergey and Dan Sheehy,
so two-- my two predecessors-- two
of my three predecessors at the NEA
in Folk Traditional Arts are here.
Let's give a hand for
there-- for them.
[ Applause ]
And there's at least two directors
of the Center for Folklife
and Cultural Heritage here,
Michael and Dan, you're two for--
[ Laughter ]
And there may be others here who
have played that significant role
in steering our federal partnerships
and what that says to me is
that our field is in many ways
still young and yet we've--
you know, here we are at this moment
where there's so much that we have
to learn from each of
you and from one another
and so I'm feeling privileged to
be up here on the stage with you --
and somewhat terrified,
so as it should be.
And--
>> Peggy Bulger: Do we?
[ Laughter ]
>> Alan Jabbour: We'll
join you in that soon.
>> Cliff Murphy: So, right.
This is like bureaucratic
fieldwork on stage.
[ Laughter ]
But I wanted to start with Alan,
you know, I'm looking at the date
of January 2nd, 1976 as the
birth date of the Center.
And I know for many of us in
the room here, we have worked
in government, federal, state
counties, city government,
trying to create programs
and that's difficult, right?
And so January 2nd is
obviously maybe the birth date,
but this whole process started
a long time before that.
I know that you are involved
in starting the first state
folklife programs while you were
at the NEA in 1974.
And, you know, when I look at that
time period in American history--
that was a difficult stretch
of time for the nation
and particularly for the government.
And, you know, at any
moment in history,
I think we think we're
in a unique time, right?
And so here we are at this
particularly interesting period
of American political
and cultural history.
There's a lot of churn and
a lot of anxiety and I think
that this Center was created at a
similar moment in American history.
And so I'm curious to know how
that felt as the new director
of the Center in terms of the
conversations that you were having
with the general public,
with government agencies
about why this mattered?
Why-- You know, why
did we need this?
How could this be a unifying force?
How did this gain political capital
to happen in the first place?
Obviously, it must have
been seen as necessary.
>> Alan Jabbour: Well, if it was
necessary, we all thought so,
but the world didn't think so.
And on the other hand, people like
Archie Green did help Congress
to think so and it did pass and,
I guess at the very end of '75,
at the end of that session
of Congress and it was
at turbulent times but it also
was a time where we were the last
of a series of Congressional
actions that we're cultural actions,
you know, including the creation
of the two Endowments in the '60s;
the creation of the Historic
Preservation programs.
Archie said he keep running in
to the historic preservation guy
who was lobbying Congress,
too, when he was lobbying
and they got acquainted
with each other that way.
And so, we were at the tail
end of that and no big ones,
that I can think of, followed us.
And on the other hand, I
don't think there was--
plenty of people of course said,
"Well, what's that going to be?"
is the policemen.
And in our field, there was
maybe some anxiety about like,
well, what's it going to do?
We've already got grants
from the Arts Endowment,
we didn't have grants from the
Humanities Endowment or at least not
on any focal and concerted
way, so there was a challenge.
And we had a great program
over at the Smithsonian,
that was a festival plus, you know,
because the Festival itself
had become a defining activity
on the national landscape--
literally and figuratively,
and the program itself, of course,
grew beyond the Festival alone.
And so some people might
have wondered, well,
what's the Folklife Center
going to do, you know?
And a number of people
in our field said, "Well,
you can be coordinative."
Coordinative?-- Coordination is an
important thing and I believe in it,
but if that's your only job, you're
not going to be able to get anybody
to pay attention, in my opinion, so.
And so you need some other things
to have attention, you know,
and then you can coordinate
more effectively
or so I believed as
the new director.
And plus we had to reassure
the Library of Congress
which accepted the Folklife Center
that possibly with some misgivings,
you know, reassure them that we fit.
And so, I then launched
a program focusing
on field documentation
evoking as history
of the archive going all the way
back to the '30s, well, to the '20s,
really, with Robert W. Gordon.
And evoking that is our
tradition, you know,
which we're now reawakening.
And so we started doing
field documentation,
but it wasn't-most field
documentation in our field
of folklore at that time was solo
work, maybe occasionally two people,
but usually people working alone.
And I was greatly taken by,
you know, the other fields
who had mounted collective projects
of a number of professionals
with varying skills, even from
different fields: anthropology
or archeology and so forth.
And I thought, "Well,
we should do that too."
Luckily, our field itself, which
had started out focusing mainly
on verbal, oral traditions
and had added music very early
in the game had started adding
in a serious way material culture
to verbal and musical traditions
as what we as folklorists did.
And so, documenting material
culture as well demanded photography
and other media of documentation.
Plus, documentation
reassured the Library
that we were building
collections, you know.
We were creating collections
which was what the Library thinks
of itself as doing either
creating collections
or at least assembling
the collections
that others have created.
The Archive historically had
done both, but had done both
at a sort of a small gauge level.
Even at that level, Alan Lomax
figured out with his dad how
to make a lot of people
notice it and think about it.
And so, think of the possibilities
if we did larger projects
including professionals
of all persuasions and specialties.
Truly documenting folklife and
in fact-- defining folklife,
not just by what we said, but by
what we did in our documentation.
Maybe I better stop there.
>> Cliff Murphy: Well, I-- you know,
I want to ask you one quick personal
question before we maybe start
to spread out a little bit and
I've reminded our panelists here
that they should feel free to
ask one another questions, too,
because I feel like that
would be interesting.
Do you remember your
first day on the job?
>> Alan Jabbour: Actually--
>> Cliff Murphy: What
did it feel like walking
in the door and here I am?
>> Alan Jabbour: Actually, the-- I
do remember it but it was an odd,
lonely day because they didn't
even know where to put me.
>> Peggy Bulger: Some
things never change, Alan.
>> Alan Jabbour: Yeah, right.
[ Laughter ]
And so, the big question
on the first day is,
where will your seat be?
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah.
>> Alan Jabbour: I couldn't even
yet quite called at in the office,
but there was a small budget, as
well as me and this was August
or September, it was
the end of the--
what was then the fiscal year
that ended September 30th.
And so, the small budget, well,
what do you do with a small budget
when you're just you
don't even have an office?
So, you-- maybe you could hire
people and I got busy hiring,
but there, that takes
dealing with the bureaucracy
which said there's no such thing as
a "folklife specialist," you know.
And so we had to invent
categories for the personnel world.
So, the one other thing we could
do is buy documentary equipment.
And my vision of what we should
do was embedded on how I spend
that small budget, you
know, in the waning days
of fiscal year, whatever
it was, '77?
>> Cliff Murphy: That sounds
like a good government
worker right there, right?
>> Alan Jabbour: And also, by doing
that to define what we were going
to do and where we
were going to go, so.
>> Cliff Murphy: Well, so, I'm
going to try to segue to Peggy here.
I know from reading your
correspondence with George Carey
in Maryland in the creation of
that state folklife program there
in the early '70s that you
had some vision of the study
of folklife including many
things that we think of as being
in the humanities-- vernacular
architecture, for instance.
Peggy, I know that when
you came onboard here
that you began working a lot
with occupational folklife
and these sorts of things.
So tell me a little bit
about inheriting this program
in this Center and this mission.
What did that feel
like as you stepped in
and where did you want
to go with it?
>> Peggy Bulger: Well, first of all,
I have to say it was
really daunting.
I remember founding out that I
got the job and I was floored.
But I have to say that anything I'm
saying really any accomplishments
really it's the staff.
I mean, I inherited
a wonderful staff.
Unfortunately, we were going
through a terrible time fiscally.
We needed to fill positions.
We had people still on
the books who were dead.
I'm not kidding, you know.
And so we really needed-- we
needed to gear up a little.
They were pulling their weight.
[ Laughter ]
Remember that?
So anyway, and I mean, Alan's
right, some things never change.
Yeah, I came, there
was no chair for me
because Alan was still working so--
[ Laughter ]
So either I had to push
him out of the chair,
which I think I did, I
may have just stayed--
>> Alan Jabbour: And they
put me up in the rafters--
>> Peggy Bulger: In the rafters...
>> Alan Jabbour: -- above
the Main Reading Room.
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah.
>> Alan Jabbour: I had
really a glorious seat.
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah.
But when I came, I think, you
know, you got to realize there's
such a difference between 1976
and 1999 in the field of folklore.
I mean, it's like night and day.
And mainly because the good works
that had been done since '76 to '99,
we now had a network of
folklorists around the country
who are doing those field projects,
using, I think, probably Alan
and his staff and the big
documentation projects as a model,
which was great because, you know,
here are all these new
programs being established.
I was in one of them.
I was in Florida.
I guess I was the sixth
state folklorist
and we would borrow
the Nagras all the time
and that was another thing I came
and there's a bunch of unused Nagras
that were, you know,
all of a sudden,
everybody has their own equipment.
So you have to re-- we were
rethinking what the Center might do
that nobody else could do.
Because there is no reason to, I
guess re-- not reinvent the wheel,
but continue with the
same wheel when it--
you are so successful that
everybody was doing great out there
and what could the Center do?
So I-- I guess when I
came, my first problem
and I think it's probably an ongoing
thing, you're always fighting
for the Folklife Center, whether
it's with the library or Congress
or whatever, you're
fighting for resources.
And as a director, I
really knew that what I had
to do was get enough resources
so the staff could do their job.
Because there's a great staff,
but if you don't have
resources, you can't do anything.
And so, we were able to hire--
I think we doubled our staff.
>> Alan Jabbour: Yes.
>> Peggy Bulger: And-- But I-- you
know, we all had to fight for it.
And we started thinking
about where we were.
Well, in the field also,
let's face it, you know,
public folklore now had a
35-year trajectory and all
of those collections are out there:
1, you know, when the state would go
out a business, you know, when they
would have their folklife program
collapse, where did
that material go?
And unfortunately, a lot of
times, it goes into the basement
of some state archive where it
was, you know, moldering a way.
So we--
>> Cliff Murphy: I've seen that.
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah,
I bet you have.
So, we were thinking about that.
Of course, we were in the process
of finalizing and we did, you know,
the Alan Lomax Collection
coming here which, you know,
started with Alan and
continued and that was a huge--
to have Lomax Collection come, I
think gave us a big shot in the arm
as far as everybody saying: "Oh,
well, maybe I want my stuff to be
over there, because
it's Alan Lomax."
And so we started getting
interest from some of the scholars
who are ready to retire and they,
you know, their house was full
of stuff and they realized we've
got to do something with it.
So we were able to really, I
think, put an emphasis now not
on field projects anymore, in
fact, we didn't have any money
to do field projects and the
other thing was we really thought
that what we had in the
archives was so important,
it needed to be preserved better
and get more staff to process it
and then to get the collections.
So I think in the first
five years when I was here,
we tripled the archive, the numbers.
But now I just said,
it's now like within--
I've only been gone four years,
you already got a million more.
You go, girl!
[ Laughter ]
You go girl.
>> Betsy Peterson: Oh I think we're
just accurately counting that.
>> Peggy Bulger: You
know, that could be.
That could be.
It's all those files I left.
>> Alan Jabbour: Can I tell about--
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Alan Jabbour: -- a quick
Peggy-related anecdote?
When I was retiring from the
Center, I persuaded the Library
that I could help facilitate the
transition to the new director
and so I was going to hang on if
they could find a place to put me.
[ Laughter ]
But I talked to a bunch of
colleagues and got, you know,
they made it clear to me that
I wasn't going to get to choose
which horse it would be, but then
I thought, well, then the trick is
to get good horses in the race.
And so--
>> Peggy Bulger: That's right.
>> Alan Jabbour: -- the personnel
office, at some point, contacted me
and said, "Well, we've got
a number of applications,"
and they read off the names.
And I said, "Oh, that's great.
Oh, you got it.
Oh, he came too."
And then I realized it was all
men, all the strong candidates.
And so-- though I didn't get Peggy
her job, she got herself the job,
I got her to apply
and I'm proud of that.
And--
[ Laughter and Applause ]
And she did the rest, you know.
>> Peggy Bulger: Sure.
You really convince me
when you said, "Well,
if you don't get the job, you'll
get a free weekend in Washington."
[ Laughter ]
That sounded good to me.
>> Cliff Murphy: That was a trip
that worked out well, right?
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah,
yeah, very great, yeah.
Anyway, so in a nutshell, though, I
think each, you know, you could look
at each decade, really, and the
way that the field has grown,
the Center, I think, needs to
respond to what's happening.
And the other thing I have to say is
that we were navigating digital
collections for the first time
and had to really fight for certain
things, like our Facebook page.
I remember Dr. Billington
being outraged that we wanted
to have a Facebook page,
you know, this was, "No, no,
we couldn't have a Facebook page."
And so, needless to say,
thanks to Steve Winick,
we have a great Facebook
page to this day,
but it took a long time to-- you
know, the Library is a big old ship
that really-- you know, it's
a great ship but it is--
it's not very nimble
on its feet, ever.
[ Laughter ]
>> Cliff Murphy: Well, now
as the Thomas Jefferson
of the presidential sequence--
[ Laughter ]
>> Peggy Bulger: Good one.
>> Cliff Murphy: Thank you.
Though Adams was only
there very briefly,
I'm not saying it was
long illustrious.
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah.
>> Cliff Murphy: Tell me how
was that experience, you know,
coming into a position where, you
know, you are preceded by two people
with significant stature
in the field and to kind
of take those reins, how
did that feel and what--
where are we now, you know?
>> Betsy Peterson: You tell me.
[ Laughter ]
No, I called Peggy on my-- the
end of my first day on the job
and started in more colorful
language and said, "What the--
How did I get myself into this?"
But, no, it's been wonderful and I--
right now, we are in the midst
of digitizing some collections
that go back to Alan's time,
the field surveys that started
in the '70s and I'm just
getting reacquainted
with all of that material now.
I'm just in awe and amazed
at what the staff was able
to accomplish in the '70s.
And also continually reminded
now that just the changes
that are happening; the changes that
Peggy, I think, begins to describe
which I think do mirror the
changes and the maturation
or trajectory of the
field as a whole.
And I do think that Alan and the
first generation really focused
on doing a lot of documentation,
going out
and actively creating material for
the archive that really did, I mean,
continue with tradition, a long
very illustrious tradition of Lomax
and Botkin and Gordon and everyone.
And I think when Peggy
and I began to come along
and I think it's just really-- it
sort of an acceleration with me,
is that the shift from going
out and actually doing the work
to eliciting the work, I think,
began to happen and I think it began
to happen for a few reasons.
Money being one, and I came in
after the recession and all of that,
and also faced a lot of
shrinking budgets as well.
But I think, you know, as I came
along, it also was about the issue
of whose-- who owns culture,
who speaks for culture,
who does field work?
And I think it sort of
points to the benefits
and the limitations
of federal government.
I think we can do certain things.
But I think for our field and that
I think for me at a certain point,
it does become an issue
of, does somebody going out
and doing fieldwork in a community
they don't really know very well,
ultimately, and may not
be staying for very long,
or how effective are they going
to be versus someone who lives
and grows up in a particular
community and has expertise?
And I think also as our field grew,
there are more and more people
with equipment, more and more
people who can do field research,
more and more folklorists
ethnomusicologists,
cultural anthropologists, and oral
historians and on and on and on.
So, I mean, we have an
incredible array of people all
over the country, all over the
world, that we can work with now.
And it was interesting,
we just finish the board meeting
this morning and we talked
about fellowships and
it's interesting: I--
when I did my dissertation,
I did my dissertation totally
with field equipment borrowed
from the American Folklife Center,
with Nagras borrowed from Carl.
And that was an incredible strategy
at that point when equipment was
so expensive that nobody
could have access to that kind
of professional recording equipment
without a program like that.
So it was unbelievable.
It really helped a
generation of people I think.
In the same way now that I think
the Archie Green Fellowships,
which started under Peggy, and other
fellowship programs, the Parsons,
the Reed, which Alan
started, and Blanton Owen.
Those are, I think, more
appropriate strategies for now.
They are encouraging fieldwork,
they are encouraging people to go
out into communities and do extended
serious in-depth field research
in a way that we couldn't do.
We just wouldn't be able to do it.
The money is not there,
the resources aren't there.
And I think those are
kinds of strategies.
I do think that's one of the
differences between the beginnings
of the Center and where
we are now in 2016.
I also think, for me, Peggy
mentioned digitalization and,
you know, digital media
and it certainly--
that shift was happening
under Peggy.
It's only accelerated, you know, at
warp speed now,and that actually,
for us or for me, one of the central
issues or thrusts that I think
or directions the Center
has to take is
to really aggressively
digitize its material,
to really aggressively get it
up online and get it available
and that means several things.
I mean, just digitizing something
doesn't make it available.
There's a whole bunch of other steps
and work that has to go into that.
And I'm committed;
the staff is committed
to really moving very
actively in that direction.
We have so much material that
you either have to come here
or it's really not all
that accessible, period.
And that's-- I mean, it's a shame.
It's-- We brought all this
unbelievable material in,
now we've got to, we've
got to get it out--
>> Cliff Murphy: Right.
>> Betsy Peterson: -- and
let people see what we have.
I mean that's one of the
major missions we have.
We also will continue
and do continue
to bring in new collections.
As Peggy mentioned, again, many
scholars, nonprofit organizations
who are a major engine for field
research in this country in the '70s
and '80s, many of them are
beginning to, you know,
looking at these collections
and realizing, "Gee,
we have masked all sorts of stuff.
What are we going to do with it?"
and nobody can get to it.
So, we are beginning to actively
work with those organizations
as well and I think those will also
continue to just enrich the archive.
But those are some of, I
think, the trajectory or some
of the differences that I see.
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah.
Well, the NCTA [National Council
for Traditional Arts] collection.
>> Betsy Peterson: Yeah, yeah, and
the Center for Traditional Music
and Dance that actually
just came to us last year.
>> Cliff Murphy: So, I'm struck by,
you know, all three of you started
out your careers in
the field, right?
You each done the significant amount
of fieldwork, important fieldwork,
and in time, you were
sucked into desk work--
[ Laughter ]
-- in a rather significant
way, right?
And I know that in the kind of the
day-to-day administrative work of--
in an organization like the
American Folklife Center or program,
there's a lot to manage, right?
And what-- I imagine that along
the way, there must be moments
that you say, "This is
why we do this," right?
And are there moments that come
to mind where you, you know,
that crystalize the mission and the
purpose of this work that, you know,
that you can kind of
look back and reflect on?
Are there?
>> Peggy Bulger: Do
you want to start?
>> Alan Jabbour: Well, many
moments, it's hard to pick one out.
At the public level, you know,
some of the accomplishments
in our era included luring
Rosalynn Carter, you know,
to an exhibit we had at the library
with Amy Carter and, you know,
it's nice getting the
president's wife looking at--
>> Cliff Murphy: Were
they in the Carter family?
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah,
the Carter family.
>> Alan Jabbour: We didn't
get the whole Carter family.
[ Laughter ]
And then, when we did our
American Cowboy exhibit,
we got President Reagan to
come to bless it as it were
in the big reception
and the opening.
And so, in terms of our public
visibility and the reassurance
that that gave the institution
that we were on the right track,
you know, those were high moments.
Field moments, of course,
I picture in the field.
I didn't get to really do
fieldwork in our field projects,
I was already the desk guy, but they
let me come and sniff, you know,
at the beginning and maybe
in the middle ones, you know.
And so I went down to South Georgia
when we were doing our project there
and couldn't resist asking around,
"are there any fiddlers
around here," you know?
And sure enough, we got
directed and Carl and I went
down to visit a fiddler, John R.
Griffin, in Lenox, Georgia and one
of my magic moments oddly is
with me playing the fiddle
like we were recording him playing
the fiddle, but he also knew how
to beat the straws and he
didn't do it with two straws,
he did it with just
one straw beating
on the strings while the
fiddle was being played.
I can't-- I don't enough time to
explain how you can beat the straw
when it's just one straw, but
it can be done and he did it.
And to demonstrate it, of course,
I had to play the fiddle and,
of course, Carl was documenting it.
And so, there are wonderful
photos of me fiddling.
John R. Griffin beating a straw on
the fiddle and on his front porch
and to me, that's fieldwork
and since I'm a fieldwork
man-- that sums me up.
But it's kind of bit of an
untruth because it suggests
that I was busy doing fieldwork
myself at the Folklife Center,
whereas a lot of the work was
fighting what people about budgets
and congressional hearings
and staff issues, personnel-
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah.
>> Alan Jabbour: --
issues, you know--
>> Cliff Murphy: Right.
>> Alan Jabbour: -- all the
things that bureaucrats need to do
and which we happily did,
but we can't claim it was
fun and remember them.
>> Cliff Murphy: Right.
How about for you, Peggy?
>> Peggy Bulger: Well, you
know, I'm thinking about this.
I think some of the best moments
were also some of the worst.
So, you know, I think about one
of the things that happened early
on when I came, Barry Bergey
and I were asked to go
to a conference in Beijing.
It was the very first conference
on intellectual property
as it pertained to folklore.
And we were representing the United
States and it began a trajectory
that I realized the
American Folklife Center,
which sits it an institution
that has the Copyright Office,
needed to be at the table when--
I couldn't believe that there
were people out there at the WIPO,
World Intellectual
Property Organization,
who are debating these
cultural issues and none
of them were called--
they were all lawyers.
They were either patent
lawyers or copyright lawyers.
There were very few and certainly
on the American delegation,
there were no "content experts."
And so, I became one of the
first content experts and sat
through agonizing,
agonizing meetings.
But it the end, I think it was very
important because if nothing else,
we were able to do a project with
Tom Rankin and Guha [Shankar] went
to Kenya working with people
who document their
own cultural tradition
so that they could maintain control
over what was happening
to their lives.
And even though we don't really know
whether that was very, you know,
ultimately long-term successful--
where it was successful,
they still talk about that
project in Geneva at these meetings
where they're talking about who
owns culture, you know, and I mean,
I could get into some really funny
stories about the discussions,
but I think it was very
important that a folklorist be
on the American delegation.
>> Alan Jabbour: Yes.
>> Peggy Bulger: I mean, you know,
it was surprising to
me that we weren't.
>> Cliff Murphy: Yeah.
>> Peggy Bulger: So that
work continues on along
with all the work that's going
on with UNESCO and there's a lot
of overlap between what's happening.
But, I think that that was one
of the things I said that's what the
American Folklife Center could do
that somebody at the state level
or a local level would not have
to gravitas, you know, "I'm in the--
I represent the federal
government," you know.
So, it was tough but
I actually enjoyed it.
You know, that's my weirdness.
>> Cliff Murphy: That's great.
And Betsy, how about
you or is it too soon?
>> Betsy Peterson: Well--
[ Laughter ]
it's-- well, it's interesting.
I mean, one of the reasons that I
really wanted to do this job was
that I knew that we are in the midst
of a massive generational shift
in the field, and just, well, every
which way you can think of, we are.
And for me, that was one
of the exciting things,
to be able to be participating
that, to be able to work,
and if any small way, you
know, have a voice in talking
about where this field, this Center
would go and that was exciting
to me, sort of more
three-dimensional
and I guess more organizational
sort of way.
I mean, by the time I came here and
I came here much later in my life
than Alan or Peggy, and so,
which is probably a good idea
because it would have been
much more difficult, I think,
and I wouldn't have
had the patience,
because things do not
move much more slowly.
But I think being able
to get new staff,
be able to begin thinking
about, for instance,
working with the federal cylinders,
I mean, the Federal Cylinder Project
and begin to reimagine what that
might be in the 21st century,
and that is really exciting.
And I should also say that for me
and in large part because of Alan
and then Peggy, I think Alan
really had to face a lot of fights
with the library, with-- I
mean, all the authorization
and reauthorization fights.
I didn't have to do that and
Peggy barely had to do that.
And that actually, I think,
made a big difference.
I also think, for me, I
actually feel pretty supported
by the library administration.
We do have to fight for resources
as every other division does,
but I actually feel that they're--
we're in pretty good shape compared
to some of the other
divisions here in the library.
And I think they actually do, at
least in the current administration,
really, I think, values what
we do and what we bring.
And with seeing with the
Veterans History Project,
I do think we are sort of hybrid
divisions, we are actively,
you know, bringing in material,
actively soliciting material
and still doing field
research as well,
unlike a lot of other divisions
who are primarily dealing
with books, serials and the like.
So we're-- And we're
actively doing programming.
We're not just the
collections division,
we're also a programming division.
And we're also trying to
move more aggressively
and to work with digital media.
And I think we're sort of showing
the way, actually, for the Library.
And I think the Library
kind of knows that.
>> Alan Jabbour: Yeah,
we're like an R&D outfit--
>> Betsy Peterson: Yeah.
>> Alan Jabbour: -- for
the Library of Congress.
>> Betsy Peterson: No, we are.
We are.
>> Alan Jabbour: And it have
been actually for a good while.
>> Betsy Peterson: Yeah.
>> Alan Jabbour: You
know, Carl [Fleischhauer]
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah.
>> Alan Jabbour: -- was really--
>> Betsy Peterson: No,
yeah, from the beginning.
>> Alan Jabbour: -- one of
the first people to experiment
with the possibilities of digitizing
collections to share them, you know.
>> Betsy Peterson:
No, and that's true.
Actually--
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah.
>> Betsy Peterson: -- one
of the Associate Librarian
in our board meeting we've just
finished was talking about how,
I think, the AFC has always been
recognized as trying to be or being
on the cutting edge of
technology and trying to grapple
with technology in the
work that we do and then
from Carl and Alan on up to now.
I think that has continued
to be the case.
>> Cliff Murphy: Well, I
should say I'm thinking about--
I'm looking into the audience here
and I know people have
some questions.
I'm also struck by-- I
know that I see Cathy Kerst
and Carl Fleischhauer
and there may be others
who have worked for
all three of you.
So--
>> Alan Jabbour: And
Judith [Gray] back there.
>> Cliff Murphy: Yes.
>> Peggy Bulger: We'll do this.
>> Cliff Murphy: Right.
>> Peggy Bulger: Oh no.
>> Cliff Murphy: Jennifer
[Cutting], right?
So, you have kind of collaboratively
assembled a staff over that time.
So, I do want to say congratulations
on putting together an
extraordinary staff here
at the American Folklife Center.
[ Applause ]
Now, before I turn you over to
your current and former staff
for interrogation, do you have
questions for one another?
Or maybe you do this
secretly over the phone?
>> Betsy Peterson: Well,
I'm-- a couple of questions.
One, are there things that you
wanted to accomplish or things
that you started that
were left undone
that you would have
liked to have achieved?
And to talk a little more about
the pros and cons of being
in a federal agency and
trying to do what we do.
I mean, for me, coming from
a background of working
in nonprofits most
of my life, I've--
well, I'm used to being having no
resources but I'm also was used
to being more nimble and
flexible in what I was able to do,
and to also be more-- you can be
a little bit more edgy when you're
in a nonprofit and
kind of pushing areas
that for a federal agency is
more difficult and may not--
I mean, may not be the role
of a federal agency that--
and I'm just curious how you all
feel about those two questions.
>> Alan Jabbour: Well, regarding
what I didn't accomplish
and happily, Peggy
picked up where I left off
on acquiring major collections
because that was one thing
that I retired feeling
that I hadn't-- I--
we had acquired collections
including some important cylinder
collections, you know.
And there, we acquired them
because we had somebody
who could do something
with cylinders
and most institutions
didn't, you know.
So, that was helpful.
But, Peggy picked up on the Alan
Lomax collection and in a way,
I think, picked up on the idea of
shifting more energy and emphasis
into collections acquisition
as a major thrust,
which I think was the-- it
was the right moment for--
and she did the right thing there.
But it also bailed me
out on things like that.
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah.
Well-- And I guess for me, actually,
I really wish that
we could have sewn
up that Seeger collection
while I was, you know,
Pete and Toshi are
friends and it was just--
>> Betsy Peterson: Don't give up.
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah,
I know, I know.
I-- I always just wanted to--
I wish I could then, you know,
while I was still there to celebrate
while they were still alive,
but some things don't
happen that way.
And I-- you know, there's always
things that you didn't get to finish
but the good news is the Center
continues, just like Alan said.
>> Alan Jabbour: Yeah.
>> Peggy Bulger: And so,
the things that are meant
to be will continue
and they will get done.
>> Alan Jabbour: Yes.
>> Peggy Bulger: It is-- And I
know I can just remember, you know,
just trying to get-- I came from
the Southern Arts Federation here
and even that, you know, that
was a nonprofit and just trying
to get a contract through could be--
So, anything that we did
actually was a real accomplishment
because we got through Napoleon
and whatever his name was
over at the contracts
office, which was like--
>> Alan Jabbour: Right,
>> Peggy Bulger: --
Napoleon and Lafayette.
There were two men.
>> Cliff Murphy: Really?
>> Peggy Bulger: Yes, I kid you not.
I kid you not.
>> Cliff Murphy: Was this when
the AFC was in Europe or--
[ Laughter ]
>> Peggy Bulger: No.
>> Cliff Murphy: So,
maybe this is a good point
to turn things over to the audience.
The people have questions, I
imagine, brave souls, anyone?
>> Female Audience member:
Can I have a question?
>> Cliff Murphy: Sure.
>> Peggy Bulger: Wow.
>> Speaker 2: What happened
with state programs?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Peggy Bulger: No,
wait for the mic.
>> Jean Gilman: Hi, I'm Jean
Gilman [assumed spelling].
I was on the board way back when
with Alan in the early days.
It was wonderful.
But what has gone on between
the American Folklife Center
and the state level programs?
Because my feeling was that they
were on the rise, that, you know,
there was a point wherein
states were appointing their
state folklorists.
But in terms of the activities
of the Folklife Center
and the state programs,
have you seen ups
and downs in those relationships?
Is that-- So maybe you
could address that?
>> Peggy Bulger: Well,
let me say something.
Because I started my career as a
state folklorist in Florida in 1976
when the Center was started and
if it wasn't for the Center,
I don't know if the Florida
Folklife Program would be around
but it's now, you know, alive
and well and continues on.
I feel like the Center at the
time, and Betsy touched on this,
was doing the right thing.
We had the Nagras, thank God we
had the Nagras from the Library
of Congress and we had
support and we could call
on our state legislature and say
there is an American Folklife Center
at the Library of Congress and
they were floored, you know.
They couldn't believe it, you know.
So I think that was
really important.
When I came in, of course, there's--
the programs were really
well-established, some.
And I have to say, the rise
of nonprofit organizations
across the country is a phenomenal,
fabulous nonprofit organizations
that have long history.
And I think we started discussions
like with the National Council
for Traditional Arts on
acquiring their collections
because they have now had 30 years,
40 years in the case of NCTA,
it's like 60 or 70 years of material
that needs to be in the right place.
And I think that a lot of
state programs and a lot
of nonprofits are looking at
the AFC as being the home,
really the preferred home for
materials, ethnographic materials.
Because we-- that's what we have.
The resources we have are-- I
mean, look at this institution
and we have, you know, archivists
and recordists and, you know,
just an amazing institution
for keeping collections, so.
>> Betsy Peterson:
Yeah, I would just add.
I mean, that network is still there,
it has certainly had
its ups and downs.
And I don't-- Cliff could
probably say, well--
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah.
>> Betsy Peterson: -- he thinks it's
in an up or a down going right now.
>> Cliff Murphy: It's
definitely in an up.
I think we feel all the
time that it's in a down.
And I'm kidding but I'm not kidding.
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah.
>> Cliff Murphy: I think that's part
of the mindset of the discipline.
>> Betsy Peterson: Yeah.
>> Cliff Murphy: But
I would say that--
>> Alan Jabbour: Occupational
pessimism.
>> Betsy Peterson: Yeah.
>> Cliff Murphy: But I think we
are-- I mean, we are in an up.
>> Betsy Peterson: Yeah.
>> Cliff Murphy: Yeah.
>> Betsy Peterson: We'll
learn also, I think the state
or more local regional programs,
where they are now is just
much more diversified.
They're not only in
state arts agencies.
In fact, I mean, that probably
is becoming smaller but they're
in universities, they're
in nonprofit stand-alones
or humanities agencies.
I mean, there's just-- it's--
the tentacles have,
you know, reached out.
So, it may not be this
one group anymore.
>> Cliff Murphy: Right.
I think it gotten a
little more diversified
that right now there are 38
active state programs and the rest
of the NEA folk arts staff
can check that figure.
And if I'm wrong, I'm happy.
If it's higher-- that's so-- yeah.
But I can say as a former, say,
folklorist that also the AFC staff
here was helpful in terms of working
with us to make sure that our
collections were organized
and that they were safe and that
they were processed properly
and that they had a home
even if that home didn't wind
up being the AFC; that they were--
they helped us to be good stewards
of that material as well, so.
Other questions?
Dan.
>> Alan Jabbour: Dan.
>> Dan Sheehy: Great to
see you all up there.
It's a beautiful sight.
Two things, first of all, the Nagra,
I can't resist mentioning this.
I was a child of the Nagra era
and this was like, oh my god,
if you have a Nagra just in your
vicinity, it was a beautiful thing.
I noticed the media director
at the Center for Folklife
and Cultural Heritage often uses
the Nagra as a doorstop these days.
They just gave a-- just kind
of a nice juxtaposition
of, you know, eras.
Question is, maybe two parts,
one is that you've had some really
notable successes in collaborations
and taking things under
your wing over the years,
the Veterans History Project,
the StoryCorps stuff that's
really punched through out there
and reached, I don't know,
how any millions but I--
so I've also noticed, for me,
anyway, one of the advantages
of projects like that is that
it tends to be reflective
of the changing demographics
of our changing nation.
And so, the sort of the two-part
question there is how you've seen--
if you've seen kind of a "feedback
loop" as Alan used to say,
Alan Lomax, of that
success coming back
and then benefiting the programs
and the whole thing
being a virtuous cycle.
And the other is that have you
seen that as yourselves as a--
an effective strategy
of both capturing
and engaging a broad diversity
of American public particularly?
>> Betsy Peterson: Yeah.
>> Peggy Bulger: Who wants to start?
Yeah.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
I'll just say real quickly
and then I'll turn it over,
is that absolutely, I'm glad
you mentioned StoryCorps.
That was one of the battles I fought
tooth-and-nail with Dr. Billington
about that I thought
it should come here.
I know probably some people
would disagree with that.
But the one thing that I have to
say is that every Friday morning,
the American Folklife Center,
Library of Congress was
on NPR on Morning Edition.
And even today, people will ask
me, I'm retired, I'm in Florida,
they'll say, "Well,
what did you do?"
I said, "Oh, I was director of
the American Folklife Center."
"Oh StoryCorps!"
They know-- If nothing else, like
they have that, you know, and they--
and then they actually have an idea
about kind of what I was about--
>> Alan Jabbour: Yeah.
>> Peggy Bulger: -- in
terms of talking to people.
So, yeah, I think it-- that's
one of the important things.
>> Betsy Peterson: Well, I
think, I mean, sort of going back
to this kind of federal government
nonprofit sort of thing, for me, I--
we are also-- we continue
working with StoryCorps
and StoryCorps continues
to innovate.
And I think for us going
forward to develop new projects,
work in new directions, we're going
to have to work with third parties.
They are those creative
engines that can push into areas
that may be difficult for us to
do or may take us forever to do.
And that's probably more--
the accurate description.
But we will need to
work with those folks.
It is getting us out into different
directions, different, certainly,
I mean, oral history is a much
bigger part of what we do.
I mean, oral history was always--
and it's sort of entwined with
folklore and ethnomusicology,
it's just sort of a part
of the mix of things.
But as in separated or
separate thing unto itself,
it's becoming more and
more prominent in our work
and that may be just
sort of the time as well.
I'm-- I'd be curious to see
if that's happening elsewhere.
Yeah, it's diversifying our methods
and the populations
that we're working with.
I don't know.
>> Alan Jabbour: That-- I
don't-- I can 't add to that.
I think that's true that you
guys did great and thank you
for fighting for StoryCorps.
That is a good fight.
>> Peggy Bulger: I think the
archivists are from [noise].
No, because it actually-- it's a
difficult collection to manage.
>> Cliff Murphy: I'm curious if
that, you know, when you talked
about unfinished business and
all but I'm wondering, too,
if you have thought
about where, you know,
I know that we're celebrating
40 years.
In another 40 years, what
should we have accomplished?
You know, what are the
challenges that face us right now?
And maybe that's too big of a
question to ask at the very end,
but, you know, what should we have
accomplished in another 40 years?
>> Peggy Bulger: Well, we
should still be around,
that's friend number one.
[ Laughter and Applause ]
That would be the major
thing, is that people would--
there would still be an
American Folklife Center
that really has a national
role and that, you know,
is viable and is doing...
I can't even imagine what 40 years
from now is going to look like
but whatever it looks
like, you know,
hopefully we would have been able
to be nimble enough
to go with the flow.
>> Cliff Murphy: Right.
>> Alan Jabbour: I think that what--
this came up in passing earlier
but one of the things I was proud
is before I retired is getting--
helping to get permanent
authorization--
>> Peggy Bulger: Yes.
>> Alan Jabbour: -- for the Center.
That is--
>> Peggy Bulger: It's a major.
>> Alan Jabbour: When it was
first created by the Congress,
it was created but it had to be
reauthorized every three years
or so by the Congress, again, as
if it were a temporary program
and needed reevaluation
and perhaps a bit.
But, getting to the point with
the Congress where they decided,
"All right, we don't have to fight
about this anymore," you know.
And the person in the Congress who
did it more than any single person,
Thad Cochran of Mississippi,
Republican Senator from Mississippi.
He was our guy.
He got it through for us.
And I think that affected
Peggy's job--
>> Peggy Bulger: Oh yeah.
>> Alan Jabbour: -- and Betsy's job.
>> Peggy Bulger: It's a major.
>> Betsy Peterson: Yeah, it is.
>> Alan Jabbour: And in a way--
>> Peggy Bulger: Major.
>> Alan Jabbour: -- turned that now
into a conversation about whether,
but a conversation about what and
what you do you can't always know
in particular terms, but if
you're there institutionally,
you'll be there when new
things, like Veterans History
or StoryCorps present themselves.
And the director, you know, will
deal with them as they come along
or maybe even invent
one for the Center
because inventing directions is good
too but most of the time, you know,
the world is busily doing things.
And if you watch the world
carefully, you'll pick up ideas
for where the future
ought to be, you know.
And inventing really doesn't have
to do with inventing from scratch
but from catching cues by
paying attention to what's going
on in the world about us.
>> Betsy Peterson: Mm-hmm.
>> Cliff Murphy: Did you want
to weigh in on the future on--
>> Betsy Peterson: Well, I
always-- when people ask those--
>> Cliff Murphy: -- 2056?
>> Betsy Peterson:
-- questions in sort
of strategic planning
exercises of, you know,
envision where you're
going to be, I just--
because I never quite know what to
say, I-- yes, we'll still be around,
the orphan works legislation will
be passed, and we will be able
to easily get more material
up online or make it more
and more accessible to
people, also the means
in which we'll be bringing stuff in,
we'll probably make it
accessible more immediately.
That we will continue
figuring out how
to balance face-to-face
interaction with tools of technology
that will allow us to,
I hope, work at a scale
that we just haven't been able
to quite manage yet, I think.
And I don't know, we'll--
>> Cliff Murphy: We'll check
back in after strategic planning.
>> Betsy Peterson: Yeah, we'll--
and what I think the tools can
make us work more collaboratively
with communities than
we've been able to do.
I mean, the impulse and the ability
to do that is always there, again,
in small-scale or targeted
ways, but I think, you know,
there are potential means for us to
really more actively bring people
into our archive, I mean,
to actively, you know,
engage and impact the
stuff that's coming in.
And I would hope to see, yeah,
that happening a lot, all the time.
>> Cliff Murphy: Do we have
time for couple more questions?
I don't know how we're doing.
One more question?
>> Nancy Groce: Maybe one more.
>> Alan Jabbour: One half question.
>> Cliff Murphy: Make it a good one.
>> Peggy Bulger: All right.
No pressure.
>> Alan Jabbour: Here it is.
>> Female audience member:
I'll ask a question.
So, as somebody that started
my dissertation research here,
obviously the collection
has provided, you know,
all kinds of not only materials
but also methodological ideas
for scholars and students
and so forth.
But I wonder if each of
you could comment on a time
when the collection meant something
for a culture bearer that came in
and discovered something
by surprise.
I know I've heard lots about
repatriation and so forth
but maybe just, you know, an
afternoon that made your day
when somebody wandered into
the archive and found something
that was actually,
by extension, theirs.
>>Peggy Bulger: George Clinton?
>> Betsy Peterson: Oh, well,
except he didn't wander
into the archive actually but--
yes, George Clinton came to visit
and I got my photo taken with
him so I was extremely thrilled.
Actually, about two months after
I started, a woman, older woman
and her grandson, I guess, came
in to the archive to listen to--
he brought her in from Baltimore to
listen to her StoryCorps interview.
And Anne [Hood] was there
and there were three or four
of us but it was her birthday.
And we all went and we stood around
and sane "Happy Birthday" to her
and it was just-- she was
beaming, it was just--
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah.
>> Betsy Peterson: --
it was wonderful, just
a sweet little moment.
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah.
>> Alan Jabbour: That's nice.
>> Peggy Bulger: Oh, go ahead.
Go ahead.
>> Alan Jabbour: I thought of, for
some reason, this popped in my mind
and Mary Hufford and others
in our office did a project
in the Pine Barrens of New Jersey.
And in the process, they have--
this was a multi-person project
and I can't even tell you
who the fieldworker was,
but one of the fieldworkers
in that project got engaged
with a small African-American
community that was Jewish, you know,
and Jewish and African-American.
And thus, from the general
Americans' point of view,
kind of an anomalist, who
are these people really?
Well, they're what they are.
>> Peggy Bulger: Twelfth
tribe of Israel.
>> Alan Jabbour: But, at some
point thereafter, I was director
of the Center but I happened to be
in the Reading Room of the archive
when a man from this
community came in.
And you could tell from his body
language that he was anxious,
like he knew these people, they come
and recorded and photographed them,
did it really go where it was said
to go to the Library of Congress?
And what was it?
You know, somehow seeing it
there was reassuring to him
that he was filled with anxiety.
And I said, oh, truthfully,
I didn't know that myself.
And so, we looked into it and
there they were, the recordings
and the photographs of this
community and we pulled them out,
he got to look at them, then
he nodded, "oh there's so
and so, there's so and so."
And you could feel the anxiety
turning to relief, you know,
as he thought this really was
the Library of Congress coming
to document us, you know.
And this is really
us and now it's here,
you know, and it's a good thing.
And for some reason, because of
the transition from anxiety to joy,
you know, it made me feel good
and remembered the moment, so.
>> Peggy Bulger: Well,
there's many moments, you know,
with members of Congress as well
as with people who would just stop
into my office and want to
just talk about the material
that their family had given.
But I have to say, you
know, I came here in 1999,
it was a different Capitol Hill, a
year-and-half later, 9/11 happened.
And when 9/11 happened,
it was tough.
But I-- And I can't remember now,
maybe the staff will help me,
we had a meeting and because
they didn't close the office,
for God's sakes, the
Pentagon is on fire
and we're still showing up for work.
So we show up for work and I
said, "Well, let's just have a--
let's go in the staff room
and have a meeting and think
about how do we respond to this."
Because at this point,
you couldn't give blood
because they have too much blood;
you could give money but,
yeah, what could we do?
And we came up with the idea
of the 9/11 Collection Project
and we just asked people, send out,
I think Ann [Hoog] was in charge
of sending out a blast email to
people around the country saying
if you have a recorder, go
out and talk to somebody
in your own community right now
what are they feeling about this.
And I-- it does-- I did
fieldwork, I took the recorder home
to Takoma Park, Maryland, and talked
to a neighbor I had
never talked to before.
She was from India and her mom
was from India, lived with her,
an elderly Indian woman who always
walked around the neighborhood
in her sari and she was terrified to
go outside because of repercussions.
And I think that was one of
the things I think that we
as folklorists are so
privileged to be able
to help people navigate these
horrible divisions that come
up where people want to divide us.
And so, that probably is my moment.
>> Cliff Murphy: I think
that's a nice moment maybe
to conclude on this.
That sounded good.
Should we give a round
of applause to them?
[ Applause ]
>> Alan Jabbour: Thank you all.
>> Cliff Murphy: Sure.
Yeah.
>> Alan Jabbour: Thank you.
>> Peggy Bulger: Oh.
>> Betsy Peterson: We will have
to get a photo of the three of us.
But, at the end of the Board
Meeting that just concluded,
Pat Atkinson presented this
to us, which is commissioned
by a leatherworker
artist traditional--
>> Alan Jabbour: How wonderful.
>> Peggy Bulger: Isn't
that beautiful?
>> Alan Jabbour: Yeah,
really beautiful.
>> Betsy Peterson:
-- a worker from--
>> Peggy Bulger: Nevada.
>> Betsy Peterson: -- Nevada.
>> Betsy Peterson: And it
will certainly go up into our,
probably in our conference room
or reading room or somewhere.
We're very thrilled.
>> Cliff Murphy: Happy birthday.
>> Betsy Peterson:
Yeah, happy birthday.
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah.
[ Applause ]
>> Announcer: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.